[Music]
the incentive to produce the best
possible technology is still going to be
there we're seeing a contest between two
very different value systems two very
different approaches hello and welcome
to chinese whispers with me cindy yoo
every episode i'll be talking to
journalists experts and long-time china
watchers about the latest in chinese
politics society and more
there will be a smattering of history to
catch you up on the background knowledge
and some context how do the chinese see
these issues in 2015 china set the
target of being a tech superpower by
2025.
that is an industrial strategy known as
made in china 2025 and it means that
china wants to move into high-tech areas
like robotics ai biotech
and also semiconductors those computer
chips that go into pretty much
everything in modern life from iphones
to unmanned drones in warfare
but china has actually been lagging
behind in this target and the world's
leading manufacturer of the
semiconductors is actually based in
taiwan given the current geopolitical
climate we're in this technological race
has become a geopolitical one an arms
race for the 21st century that's what
i'm going to be talking about in this
episode today my guest is nigel inkster
who is a former mi6 director and now a
senior advisor on cyber security and
china for the think tank iiss and also
author of a book called the great
decoupling which is all about america
and china's respective quests for
technological dominance and the
decoupling in global supply chains that
might come about nigel welcome to
chinese whispers to start with can you
explain what is a semiconductor um and
what are they useful well semiconductors
um you know to answer the second part of
your question first they're used for
pretty much everything these days the
other there are very very few uh
machines devices that are not uh
critically dependent upon semiconductors
they are essentially in effect a kind of
micro uh electronic switch you know they
enable you know um circuits to you know
open and shut um and through that to um
you know
enable
a huge variety of electronic devices to
work and as i understand it size matters
insofar as the smaller the better and
cutting edge the most cutting edge at
the moment is about three nanometers is
that right
yes i mean three nanometers is uh you
know just uh starting to you know uh be
a production feature
um in fact you know um
the vast majority of semiconductors that
are in common use are nowhere near that
small
um you know
anything from 64 to 28 nanometers uh is
much more common and the problems that
we've been seeing globally in relation
to areas like the motor industry
um you know the shortages there are not
of these
very high-end um minute uh microchips
that you know they're they're you know
the much
larger more um more commonly available
having said commonly available the
production of these things uh is in no
sense a trivial undertaking
i mean it's very expensive as i
understand to each generation billions
of dollars
yes well if we're talking about uh you
know three nanometers uh to set up um um
a fabrication plan to fab as it's termed
in the trade we're talking somewhere
between 15 and 18 billion dollars and
once you've actually made that
investment
you have to
maximize production for as long as
possible in order to amortize that
investment it's a very complicated
process you've got to build the fab
you've got to acquire the etching
machines which each of which will cost
you between two and 300 million
dollars and
you also need to set up a very complex
and sophisticated supply chain in the
chemicals and materials that you're
going to need
to operate the plant
added to which you know if anything goes
wrong uh shutting down the plant and
then reopening it as a major undertaking
it's not a trivial matter just switching
turning off a switch turning it back on
again
and costs matter i mean it's very
interesting for example the
one of the founders of the taiwanese
tsmc corporation which is manufacturing
now at this three nanometer production
node
uh gave an interview recently where he
talked about relative costs uh made the
point that in the united states
uh production costs were
uh persistently and stubbornly 25
percent higher than in taiwan which made
um the prospect of opening
uh tsmc fabs in
the usa
not very attractive commercial
proposition but it is being done more
actually for political reasons yes well
let's definitely talk about that um you
mentioned taiwan semiconductor
manufacturing company which is the world
leading company doing these cutting-edge
things um can you give us an idea of the
market dominance of them how good are
they
how important well i mean
um
just to dial back briefly
um most of the intellectual property and
design
of these microprocessors is done in the
united states but the united states does
not
now produce many of these
microprocessors i think only about 12
percent of global supply is actually
manufactured in the united states and
most of that is done by one major
corporation intel
there are only two other games in town
when it comes to the very advanced uh
high-end microprocessors and that is
samsung in korea
and
tsmc
in taiwan
and thai the tsmc
fabs in taiwan
um specialize in producing
other companies designs so you've got
your major design companies in the
united states qualcomm nvidia etc they
design
the microprocessors and tsmc produces
them
samsung is a kind of
intermediate um situation because they
manufacture for their own devices but
also
they
make um to other people's designs intel
only up until now has manufactured for
intel's own
machinery and equipment so tsmc is
unique in that it only
manufactures other people's design
and over the years and tsmc has taken
massive gambles
in investing in in this very uh complex
and expensive process making it in
effect the world leader and i think
it's very difficult to say categorically
but it's possible that ts that tsmc may
account for 60
of the world's most advanced
microprocessors so it is absolutely um
market critical i mean it's incredible
that this chip that is so important to
everything in daily life is so market
dominated by one factory in or one
company i should say in taiwan um
especially when taiwan is such a
precarious place which i i will we'll
get on to
soon well i think that the other point
there is that there out of the three
major manufacturers are advanced
microchips two are in geopolitically
very unstable locations that's tsmc and
samsung yes that's true
um so how is it that a taiwanese company
has had such market dominance in doing
that then is it just because of a
globalized world american companies
relying on you know there is no reason
not to import this kind of stuff if you
don't have to put in the cost of
manufacturing yourself
well exactly i mean
and of course you know
manufacturing taiwan is as we just said
um
very considerably cheaper than in the
united states
well i think it's just a function of of
the fact that the united states is you
know a a very high you know high cost
society um
and you know that that impacts on
everything it impacts on you know the
wages you have to pay your workers it
impacts on your taxes you know
everything that you know all the inputs
into the process are just that much more
expensive in the united states because
it is you know a more developed economy
so yes i mean i think it's been one of
those situations where
you know taiwan
has um identified this area as um
a kind of uh area for for
for nation you know developing a
national champion and this has been a
mutually beneficial arrangement and i
think it's important to emphasize um
that the manufacturer of microprocessors
is a highly
uh globally integrated
system i mean you've got you know gsmc
is manufacturing um
these things but it's getting the
designs from the united states it's
getting the
equipment to etch the circuits from the
netherlands it's getting um
chemicals from japan from germany
and um the uh the the packaging and
distribution is actually largely done in
china in mainland china
so the whole thing is hugely integrated
yeah i mean
very symptomatic of the globalized world
that we've just gone through in the last
few decades which viewing your book
looks at in terms of whether or not it
will last and let's talk about that in a
bit but for now let's let's talk about
the people's republic of china um in
2015 the government set up the made in
china 2025 industrial strategy which is
aimed at taking china higher up the
values chain when it comes to
manufacturing so
not toys and clothes but renewables ai
biotech and semiconductors
but nigel when the industrial policy was
first announced in 2015 um
it had the target of basically doing 40
meeting 40 of its domestic demand by
2020 or for semiconductors and 70 of its
domestic demand in semiconductors by
2025. how successful has china been in
meeting those targets
and not very is a short answer i mean
the fact is that china is um investing
very heavily in
microprocessor production
um
and um huge um in financial incentives
are being offered um
by different provincial and municipal
administration to attract
startups um
to to get in into this business
but i think since 2015 china's
industrial policy has evolved
and i think it's quite clear that uh
under xi jinping
the vision for the future is
um
small and medium um startups focusing on
industrial production and we're seeing
now that xi jinping himself is showing
very pronounced marxist tendencies in
that he
looks at
the economy in terms of production and
distribution
um has little time for
or little interest in in in consumption
and we've seen in the last uh two to
three years that these consumer facing
mega corporations in china like alibaba
and 10 cent have come under a lot of
government pressure
and the focus now as i said is very much
on
industrial production
developing um these capabilities uh to
enhance china's manufacturing and
production capabilities i mean there is
a phenomenon in china um that is
referred to as
the indus the the industrial party it's
not of course a party
about what it is is a kind of loose
coalition of of of young chinese
engineers who who see china's future
very much in terms of this industrial
production and i think you know this is
a reflection of the way the country is
is looking at the issue when you say
industrial production is that high-tech
industrial production as well yes it is
yeah absolutely i mean the the aim is to
go as high up
the value chain as quickly as possible
and to the extent that it is possible uh
achieved something close to um global
dominance in the tech sector the way
that the united states has enjoyed uh
that status you know for the last 40 50
years so why is it that china hasn't
been able to crack that industry when it
comes to semiconductors
well i mean the there are you know it's
not the only industry where china is
still struggling i mean you know uh aero
engines for for commercial airliners is
another area where where china
stubbornly um
fails you know to make the grade but i
think the problem is in china that it
goes back i i made the point in my book
back to the 1960s when china's
understanding of
transistors and microprocessors was
broadly on a par with that of the united
states but following all the turmoil of
the cultural revolution the disparaging
of intellectuals and all that sort of
thing
um china basically dropped um a whole
generation of
of scientific and uh
engineering process and
progress and it's never really recovered
from that
and you've got um
you do have a lot of
very capable young chinese
engineers who are now working in the
industry
um but you know the big problem for
china at the end of the day is that
china has not been able to develop
these very advanced uh ultraviolet uh
lithographic um
systems that are
effectively dominated by two uh
corporations and actually you know in
practice really one asml which is a
dutch corporation
and because the equipment this deep
ultraviolet lithography and now extreme
ultraviolet lithography is so dependent
upon uh us intellectual properties the
united states government is pretty much
able to dictate uh the terms on which a
asml can sell its equipment um to to to
other countries and we're seeing now the
united states government uh apparently
planning to crack down on this to the
point where china's
mfa press focus on charlie chen
talked about uh technological terrorism
um
you know in in terms of you know the
fact that the united states is planning
to deny
uh china access to this equipment and as
i said it's not just the equipment this
is one of these businesses where
you know if you get if if you were able
to acquire the equipment if you were
able to so to speak steal the blueprint
you still wouldn't be there because you
don't have the experienced
workforce that is going to actually
operate this kit you don't have the
supply chains that you need to ensure
timely and effective uh delivery of all
the inputs that you're going to need to
to to deliver the the appropriate
quality so it is an uphill struggle and
it's not just something that you can
solve by throwing money at and this was
a difference when china wanted to have a
network of high-speed rails it was
relatively straightforward they just
stole the blueprint blueprints from
japan threw money at it literally
through espionage yeah yeah yeah and and
and you know uh through you know
patience and persistence they they got
actually very quickly uh uh a national
high-speed rail network um this is one
of the microprocessors are not that sort
of technology
there is a german term fingerspitzka
literally meaning fingertip feel
which
refers to the kind of innate
knowledge that is very difficult to
explain it's something you acquire by
doing it and and and this is a key area
where china still is is behind so time
really matters that the amount of time
doesn't matter absolutely and the other
thing of course is it's possible that
china might be involved in a kind of
zeno's paradox race you know where where
where where the you know the the
hair never actually
achilles never actually overtakes the
tortoise
everyone else is going by so quickly
well yes and the other point is of
course we are coming to a point um you
know not yet but it will happen when you
know so-called moore's law the
proposition that the capacity of
microprocessors increases roughly every
24 months
will come to an end you're talking about
production at the three nanometer
node
well the size of a silicon atom is 0.2
nanometers
once you hit that
you've nowhere else to go
so there will come a point you know at
some point where it's going to be very
difficult to
etch yet more complex circuitry into yet
tinier microscopic uh slivers
of silicon now there are ways around
this you're moving from electronic to
photonic
um
um and you know as a way of um you know
optimizing um
you know the ability of these small
chips to function um there are other
materials rather than silicon that could
be used gallium an obvious case in point
um you know these things are in the
future but the point is it is a you know
um it is going to be one of these
situations where
you know there will come a point at
which we we kind of run out of road in
terms of how we're producing these
things at the moment and the question is
will china ever sort of catch up and is
it does it make good economic and
commercial sense for china to try to do
that
yeah i mean in a globalized world you
can just get your stuff wherever right
but i think that's a well indeed big
assumption right now
um yeah but before we move on to the
geopolitics nigel some in the west might
say that um only innovative societies
politically free societies societies
that encourage critical thinking can do
this kind of cutting-edge technology um
matt ridley for example a spectator
contributor has a book exactly on this
called how innovation works do you think
that's part of china's problem
it could be i mean i think we should you
know we don't we don't need to we should
be careful about making too
easy generalizations about this kind of
thing if you look at the soviet union
during the cold war for example uh we
saw it was hardly a free society um yet
we saw some quite significant uh
technological innovations let's say you
take the kalashnikov um
um you know the the you know the most
commonly available uh firearm in the
world you know it it it was a soviet um
uh military officer um who
you know decided that he was going to
work out how to combine the best
features of a rifle in the submachine
gun in one
item
and um you know that that was uh very um
successful in the 1950s you know it
looked as if the soviet union was going
to uh beat
the united states in the space race um
you know so on and so forth so i don't
think it's that entirely that
straightforward
but at the same time i do think that um
there are risks associated with an
excessively statist
approach uh to running these things and
i think that is we're going to see this
um with china's efforts
uh to dominate global technical
standards which is a major
um
focus
of of the xi jinping
administration um the way um it it's
working at the moment we're going to see
the state uh more uh actively involved
in working with um industry uh to
develop uh technical standards i mean
there is a risk there that if the state
gets too much involved you end up in a
situation where you're kind of baking in
obsolescence rather than creating uh the
circumstances for genuine continuing
innovation there's a big risk in that
can you explain what you mean by
technical standards
all electronic equipment in the world
and this is absolutely everything from
the most you know advanced micro
processors to to to the you know device
that you plug into the wall to charge
your phone all of these things are
designed to internationally agree
technical standards
and
the point is you know the the country
that
whose technical standards get adopted
internationally
stands to benefit very significantly
both economically because every time
somebody develops a device using these
standards they pay royalties
and china pays huge amounts of royalties
including to the united states for
things like software
so if you you can
get
the world to accept or a significant
part of the world to accept that your
technical standards are the ones that
should be adopted
um you benefit um economically both
because people are paying you royalties
and they're buying your kit
or the you know or kit that is designed
or on your standards but it goes beyond
that because if you look at the way the
internet developed in the 1990s and the
2000s
it had u.s values baked into it so to
speak
and i think that china would like to see
a world in which the next generation of
technical standards had chinese values
baked into them
and you see this for example with the
the the way in which china um sells its
um
communications networks to to to the
developing world you know they have all
the capabilities for authoritarian
oversight and control that are you know
uh commonplace within china's own
uh networks and so you get a kind of um
reinforcing process in which your values
your approach your way of doing things
gradually becomes the accepted global
way of doing it yeah i had um jingtu
from yale university on recently um and
her book kingdom of characters mentioned
the early telegraphy moment where based
on morse code it was based on alphabetic
english the english alphabet and china
really struggled with adapting that to
its own language so i guess it's just a
modern version of that
oh yes indeed i'm old enough to remember
you know i can still remember the
chinese commercial codes for some of the
uh most common chinese characters
known i don't know how many people not
many people
can any longer do that nor is it a
particularly useful skill
helps a little grey cells
um
okay so
let's talk about the the geopolitics of
the whole thing then because clearly
america and china both see it as a
national security issue well actually
can i say that can i say clearly that
both i see it as a national consequence
yeah absolutely yeah i think it's
perfectly fair yeah okay um and so
there's an arms race that's happening
and you've already mentioned the
american efforts to basically hobble
china in its catching up um
in your recent book you've talked about
how that race will lead to a great
decoupling of tech and supply chains
between the west and china we've i think
listeners have already had an idea of
just how integrated and global the whole
process is at the moment so what do you
foresee happening then in the next 10 20
years with this great decoupling
well um you know
as uh
the great yogi berra once said never
make predictions especially about the
future but um you know one can see you
know sort of possible ways in which uh
this situation uh might might evolve
um and you know i suspect that you know
one very likely outcome
um is a world um that um
is kind of bifurcated uh with some
countries using us-based uh
technological systems
others using
um
chinese
systems and some countries possibly
operating a hybrid um arrangement where
you know to some extent they use both
which of course would be highly
inefficient add uh considerable costs
but may be the way to go i mean i'm sure
you're aware you know that when you go
on the the chinese internet it is
already in many ways a very different
experience to using you know western
internet um you know it is at once
similar um but in other ways uh very
different and you know those those
differences are to a significant degree
cultural
um rather than technical the technology
the underlying technology is is
essentially the same the way it is
applied
uh is actually quite different
um so i mean i think that that that is
uh one possibility but i think what we
what we are going to see
um is
what we are already in and will probably
be in for some considerable time is is a
kind of messy uh undetermined uh
situation in which
you know neither side is going to be in
a position to declare victory
uh to say uh well you know sort of you
know we we've taken over the world and
everybody's going to you know do it our
way
um so um
you know there's going to be a lot of
uncertainty a lot of competition uh
going on
um it's not always necessarily going to
be the best technology
uh that comes out on top because
politics and geopolitics are going to
play a very
considerable
role uh in in all of this
but the incentive uh to produce the best
uh possible technology is still going to
be there and ultimately there's a
question about you know whether a status
chinese model
um
can
in the long term perform better
than the u.s uh laissez-faire model
uh and we don't know the answer to that
question you know for years in the west
we've taken it as an act of faith the
the the laissez-faire system will always
develop
better results that the market you know
will um you know sort of sort things out
even though adam smith uh
um was quite clear that it wouldn't
always and governments would need
sometimes to intervene to take
corrective action
um and so we're seeing a a contest
between two very different value systems
two very different approaches
um and it is absolutely unclear um how
that is going to play out in china it is
an article of faith that the chinese uh
um system socialism with chinese
characteristics all the new era
yeah exactly
don't you love these sort of snappy you
know uh you know appealing you know
titles they come up with yeah um either
they must prevail um and you know that
that is you know that has been very very
clearly and repeatedly stated
um
we will see but can i push back on that
nigel and say that the american
government is getting quite involved
when it comes to technology and
certainly semiconductors we've already
talked about export controls that
doesn't just apply to american companies
as you say they're pressuring the dutch
government
and the japanese governments to not um
supply china with the relevant
components in this industry um as i
understand it the arizona plant that
tsmc is opening was came about from
political pressure from the trump
administration absolutely so the
government is putting its aura in and i
you know do you think that that's a
obviously there's a trump era legacy but
it doesn't look like biden's going to
overturn or any success of american
governments
um well that that seems to be uh an
issue and uh debate within washington at
the moment and the moment is rather
narrowly focused on whether existing
trump tariffs should be maintained or
whether some of them should be lifted
whether it would be in
u.s interest to do so
uh but yes i mean i think that uh you
know the
uh i mean again you know
every country has its national uh myths
and and the united states national myth
is one of you know untrammeled free
enterprise it's never been like that
since the 1890s you know when roosevelt
brought the you know the the oil
companies and the banks to heal
ever since then you know the united
states government has been ready to
intervene um and as and when necessary
and you're absolutely right i mean we've
seen um i mean there is a bill going
through uh congress at the moment called
the um united states uh competition and
innovation act that provides for i think
250 billion dollars
in funding
uh most of which is designed to
ensure that the united states can remain
competitive vis-a-vis china and actually
this is seen in china as such a threat
that china has threatened
um
unspecified retaliation if this uh act
uh is passed into law which i think it
very well will be albeit not in its
current form
um so yeah i mean you know the the us
government is um getting um very
actively involved it's used uh the um
it's used the entities list
uh an arrangement which was designed uh
to prevent um
equipment uh and know-how going to
countries uh uh to to develop um
uh weapons of mass destruction programs
um
to to deny access uh uh to chinese
companies of u.s um
technology and inputs um and and we're
seeing if anything um that uh
restrictive approach uh broadening um
under biden and and the mood uh within
washington within the beltway is such i
think it would be very difficult for any
administration to suddenly turn around
and say let's make nice with china you
know this is just not you know a
realistic political possibility in in
today's america well is it also
effective in so far as you know when it
comes to semiconductors one victim
chinese victim has been huawei which was
subject to export controls in the chips
that are needed has that worked has it
been working
yeah well and certainly it has
kneecapped huawei's mobile um
technology sector and huawei has had to
move um into
other um areas uh cloud computing uh
being being the main one so yes i mean
huawei uh definitely was um very badly
affected by um what the united states uh
did
um i mean china's
5g networks uh are moving ahead
um
but
perhaps slower than they would
otherwise have done uh the united states
is now rolling out 5g networks so most
people i know who've got them say
there's no
perceptible difference from 4g
um actually that was to be expected to
start with you know when you get a new
generation of mobile technology the way
it evolves is very dependent upon um
sort of called vertical use cases right
so you know so when you get this
technology how it evolves how it
develops is critically dependent upon
how key
industries and key actors choose to
utilize it and develop it so it's still
in it sort of the embryonic state in
that respect but yes i mean what what
what uh the us has done um visibly
huawei and other is now planning to do
with other chinese companies is going to
have um an impact and no question about
it but of course only that only takes
you so far yes you can slow china down
but then can you speed america up
you know that is actually the more
important um uh
question uh to answer because if all
you're doing is you know
you know sort of kneecapping your
opponent but not actually running in the
race
um
you know
uh you're ultimately not going to
achieve very much and this i think you
know is my big worry is that uh if we do
end up in this um progressive uh
technology decoupling i i think
everybody is going to be a loser i don't
think there are going to be winners in
in
in
in this competition because you know
today these technologies have been so
dependent upon global integration uh the
interchange of ideas
um
and um if we're going to
end up dealing with two sealed systems
well we know um the second law of
thermodynamics tells us what happens in
a sealed system you get entropy
brilliant um but nigel surely in this
race um america has the upper hand and
plain devil's advocate here in that it's
got taiwanese it's got its own know-how
it's got a taiwanese manufacturing and
soon it will have it in its own um
country in arizona um as you mentioned
samsung is the second market leader
that's south korea's
american ally
um surely in this kind of race just on
semiconductors alone america has the
upper hand
well america does have the upper hand at
the moment it's still several
generations ahead of china in terms of
design um
and
um you know for the reasons we've talked
about it's actually going to be quite
difficult for for for china to catch up
um i suspect something similar may be
going on with artificial intelligence
um that that one is more difficult
because what we talk about you know we
talk about ai which you know
we tend to
actually use it as shorthand for for
machine learning um you know the the you
know
this stuff is
still actually
very fragile and uh unpredictable in in
the way that it works
but i think that the united states uh
retains
a corpus of expertise
uh here that china cannot yet match
indeed it it remains the case that the
majority of chinese experts in ai aren't
actually working in china they're
working in america
so you know there are issues here
although the americans are trying hard
to get them to go back to china
i know yes indeed well yeah i mean
well no nobody ever said that western
governments are not capable of uh acts
of uh you know sort of um
self uh you know
indeed yes i mean let's look at brexit
as an example of that let's not get on
to brexit
and what about rare earths is that
something i mean am i right in thinking
that rare earth is a fundamental
material that is needed for
uh semiconductors and china controls i
think
80 percent of the wild supply
yeah yeah i mean the thing is rare earth
the term rare earth is a bit of a
misnomer because these things aren't
actually that rare okay yeah they're
they're quite abundant and quite widely
distributed america's got lots of them
uh so has canada so has australia um you
know there are other places within uh
the u.s um
sort of geopolitical orbit uh that have
these things the problem with these rare
earths is that they are extremely dirty
and polluting to produce and uh until
recently china has been the only country
that has been willing to
um shoulder that cost but also in africa
right chinese companies
well i mean some of these
raw materials in lithium in particular
um you know the um cobalt uh the focus
has been you know the these have been
coming from um
from africa from the democratic republic
of of congo in particular but there are
other countries you know latin america i
mean countries like chile um
bolivia have have got you know
significant uh deposits of or or of
these minerals they said that you know
the real problem is you know the the the
processing which is you know
expensive dirty polluting
uh china's doing a lot of this
production in um in mongolia
which has large swathes of uh um land
that nobody's uh ever going to live on
um so it's a relatively kind of
you know it's relatively speaking easier
for them to take that hit
but the united states was the country
that first
started to mine and process uh rare
earths actually as a byproduct of other
more conventional mining operations
um and if they're prepared you know to
to to assume uh the risks um you know
the environmental costs um they can
perfectly well um
produce these things uh for themselves
so i think it unlikely that china is
going to
um
remain you know uh re retain a a
chokehold in fact a few years back uh
china did um withhold supplies of rare
earths from japan
um in in retaliation for something the
japanese did i can't remember what um
and in fact what happened was that the
japanese uh just
resourced
um those those rare earths and the net
result was that uh china simply lost
market share
okay so it's more it's more complicated
than that having said that of course the
fact that china does
uh have such a high percentage dominance
in the production of these things um
does give it some leverage no question
yeah
and the ultimate thing that china can do
which we've been quite good at not
mentioning so far um but is invading
taiwan and overtaking tsms nc
so i think some people in washington are
worried about that
i think they are yes i mean the
taiwanese tend to blightly say oh well
this is our silicon shield
china would never uh take the risk of um
seeing the tsmc fabs uh destroyed um
in order to to to retake uh the island
i'm not persuaded of that
at all i think um you know like like a
lot else to do with taiwan's attitude
towards its own defense there's a
certain uh delusional uh element uh
there
but you know the fact is um
that
the
tsmc um
[Music]
fabs
um
you know are are a source of potentially
serious risk and you know the the
question is you know in in
um an invasion in in a violent invasion
scenario
um
would the taiwanese government would the
united states
um
be ready
to
destroy these fabs rather than let china
get hold of them i mean if we look at in
an analogous situation switzerland in in
the early 1940s everyone assumed that
nazi germany was going to invade the
swiss sent a message to berlin saying if
any uh german forces across our border
you know our army will destroy the
country's industrial infrastructure
below the dams flood the central plains
and take to the hills to conduct
guerrilla warfare
so faced with the
prospect of acquiring a totally
unproductive and useless piece of real
estate hitler opted not to invade now
you know taiwan potentially could do
something similar but so far it hasn't
do we have any signal from washington or
taipei that it is thinking about doing
it that it might lean towards that as a
policy not not that i'm aware of no do
you think it's actually
a deciding factor a carrot for china to
invade taiwan is there something that
could change
well you know you would think so but
i've not seen
any uh discourse to that effect
so i think there's an open question i
mean i'm not saying you know i mean i'm
not claiming to have all the answers
here particularly in relation to a
country as opaque as china is
um i've just not seen any you know
publicly articulated discourse around
this issue do you think that in in this
decoupling scenario that could happen if
if china is not getting the chips from
tsmc anyway it may as well just invade
if if america pressures um this kind of
deep coupling to the extent that china
can't get its components i mean i think
there may be a strain of thought which
says effectively um
you know the one thing china has got in
its favor is that it does uh manufacture
a very significant proportion of the
world's um uh less sophisticated uh
microprocessors from the sort of 24
nanometers upwards as it were
um
and um there
there could be a kind of er erostrata's
kind of mindset you know that uh you
know um erastratus being the guy who
decided he was going to seek notoriety
by burning down
the temple of diana deficits
um you know it is possible the chinese
might say right if we can't have it
nobody can have it um and uh you know
even if we lose this we will still uh be
able to manufacture at the higher uh
production loads uh and this will give
us a kind of
a strategic advantage yeah that is a
possible
train of thought as i've said i've not
heard this um articulated of course um
and i also want to bring it back to the
uk because in the uk now um nigel you
and i we've spoken about the live
political question over the acquisition
of newport wafer fav by a chinese
company
it's a welsh semiconductor manufacturer
and
basically the government did a national
security review of it stephen lovegrove
concluded that it was not a national
security concern quasiquad and the
business minister secretary told him to
go back um and look again
are you sure
um because clearly politically you know
if china
acquires the argument goes if china
acquires a manufacturing capability um
and it is part of made in china 2025
that it is creating national champions
but also acquiring foreign manufacturing
so it is part of the strategy um that it
could you know it feels like the west is
shooting itself in the foot why would
the uk let that happen
but you expressed doubt about it when we
last talked about it can you explain
well i think that you know i mean the
newport doesn't manufacture very um
high-end uh very you know advanced uh
microprocessors i think the issue in
relation to newport may be what less one
of uh national security
um
than uh uk industrial patrimony
you you know how yeah
you know um
does it make sense uh to lose this kind
of capability
because once lost it's not easy to to to
get it back um and i think one of the
things
people are beginning to wake up and
realize about uh de-industrialization
uh in the west in the united states in
europe
um
is that with industrialized
de-industrialization
comes
a loss of
expertise culture
you know workforce skills
um that are very difficult to recover
so i think the question is probably less
you know is is this a sort of security
dagger poised at the heart of uh um uh
uk um national security or is it um a
question of um
the advisability
of the uk losing you know
these skills and capabilities and i
think it's more that but i think
national security as a term has been
broadened now hasn't it in in this arms
race world that we're in um absolutely i
mean you know xi jinping's concept of
comprehensive uh national security
effectively incorporates everything
perhaps as it should yeah well um i mean
i think this is the reality i mean we've
seen a progressive
expansion of what people think of um as
meaning national security
um you know not long ago it was very
narrowly defined
um in terms of you know it's a largely
sort of military uh focus but um you
know concepts of security have been
significantly evolving since then and
and continue to do so
and you also previously mentioned that
newport wafer fab actually was doing
quite
low end stuff yes
how can you give us an idea of just how
advanced i think it i think the the the
the the i'm not absolutely sure but i
think the you know the the
best they can do is 28 nanometers okay i
think but is that what the chinese can
already do themselves anyway which
they're going to really do yeah right
okay and nigel just finally as soon as i
have you here and i want to get your
thoughts on the recent tens house joint
speech by the um heads of mi5 and the
fbi and for listeners who don't know uh
the director-general of mi5 and the
director of the fbi said that they had
more than double the effort against
chinese activity of concern um and that
china poses the biggest long-term threat
threat to national security for the west
and it's made headlines um as perhaps it
should because it is quite a exceptional
joint speech but at the same time these
are things that we already knew didn't
we i mean as a former intelligence
officer i would wondered what you
thought about the speech well you know
you you and i know about this because of
course we follow these uh issues very
closely
but i think you know i mean i i don't
know uh exactly what the motivation was
for this joint presentation but what i
strongly suspect is that it reflects a
perception by both the fbi and the and
mi5
that you know the threat from china is
is growing unmanageably large uh and in
order to deal with it uh there needs to
be an important uh exercise in public uh
consciousness raising
because i think the giant you know the
chinese have been quite adept at
operating within some gray areas um
um and um you know in the united kingdom
in particular um
activities like
elite capture you know sort of paying
senior retired people large sums of
money to occupy cinecures
um and then use them to either promote
uh china's points of view or maybe also
um help you know gain access uh to to to
things that china wants um and you know
there's a lot of concern about uh
engagement uh
um
between academic institutions
universities and so on um in which um
there is a risk of important uh
technology um leeching away
um all of these factors come into it so
i think it's not you know um i think
that you know a lot of people tend to
assume
that you know there's a real espionage
threat in the united kingdom sort of
comes from countries like russia using
very traditional
techniques and tradecraft uh china has
you know uh chinese intelligence
services have a looser approach
to things like tradecraft and indeed you
know intelligence collection is not just
the preserve of china's intelligence
agencies lots of other um
entities are involved and the point i
made in my book great decoupling is that
you know china we need to think of china
to some extent as an intelligent state
in much the same way as the venetian
republic was in
his apogee in the 16th and 17th century
when when intelligence collection and
covert acquisition was kind of
built into the fabric of the state such
that almost anybody could find
themselves involved
in intelligence work and i think we're
seeing something similar now in china
and you know conveying an awareness of
that
um you know alerting people
to the potential risks of getting
involved in what on the face of it
seemed like innocuous activity
i think you know this is the real
message that
that uh mccallum and ray were trying to
you know to put across
fascinating nigel we must have you back
on the show just to talk about espionage
of course um nigel inkster thank you so
much for joining chinese whispers
a pleasure thank you cindy
thank you for watching this episode of
chinese whispers if you've just come
across the podcast on youtube you can
find more episodes through searching for
chinese whispers wherever you get your
podcast from there is a brilliant
backlog of episodes not on youtube and
if you have feedback do leave a comment
below preferably constructive and
subscribe to the spectator's youtube
channel so you never miss any of our
spectator tv shows thanks for watching
[Music]
you